this thing that you do when you just
break out of the song is this something
that she does all the time are you like
hanging out in the office and then she
just busts in like i have to force it
i have to force it but sometimes i'll
just wander over to the piano at home
and just start playing and then she'll
come and you know come behind me and put
her arms around me just start singing
but we don't do it a lot that was the
only one but um i i love hearing her
bust out i mean she's got such a great
voice and you can catch her great voice
alongside other broadway talent tomorrow
night at the david foster foundation's
annual fundraising gala it's been a
while since you've had the opportunity
to do the gala what does it feel like to
be able to come back we had some great
zooms cocktail zooms but to be live is
going to be amazing you know we have a
young baby and so i it's actually that
has had an impact on me and what we do i
mean sometimes you know sometimes i'm
not gonna lie you go through the motions
because there's so many families that we
help and having a baby just sort of
brings it all full circle and i know cat
feels the same way yeah when you have a
new baby you just can't imagine anything
happening to them you know i've known
david for a long time before we were
even a couple and i've known about his
foundation so for me it's incredible to
watch uh what he and so many of his
people who work for the foundation have
created it's really it's incredible
between you know work and life family
life the kids it can be difficult to do
things like get a date night would the
gala be considered a date night for you
guys is that what this this is really
about
no it's work i mean sunday night on
sunday which is mother's day is it a
surprise do you know what he has planned
or no no we're not revealing anything
it's a joke i like basically
i basically you can see me
what's the perfect date night for you
well a gala would be great just saying
you got to get a suit pressed yeah keep
going out yeah don't go like that
wait what